the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 video in today's video I want to talk
about our favorite red priestess
Melisandre before we get started I just
want to give everyone a heads up the
winner of the giveaway will be announced
at the end of the video so for those of
you that entered and make sure you stay
until the end to find out if you won now
let's get started if you have stayed
up-to-date with some of my previous
Melisandre videos then you would know I
believe Melisandre will sacrifice
herself in order to help Jon Snow and
Daenerys Targaryen defeat the night king
the reason why I say that is because
Melisandre has been preparing for this
day ever since she was introduced during
Melisandre introduction she held a
ceremony where Stannis Baratheon pulled
a flaming sword out of the chest of one
of the statues on the beach of
Dragonstone
the ceremony was held as the red comet
was flying high across the sky and I
believe this will actually come into
play when Melisandre finally performs
the ultimate sacrifice which is
sacrificing herself for the greater good
of the realm with the limited
information we have we know Melisandre
was last seen on Dragonstone talking to
Varys as Jon Snow and Davos began to
walk to the castle to greet what
Daenerys Targaryen
during Melisandre's last conversation
she did say a few interesting things
which could indicate what will happen in
her storyline in the final season she
told Varys she was heading to volantis
but she also said she would be returning
most likely right in time for the battle
against the night king as we all know
Melisandre also said something very
ominous to Varys she did say both of
them would die in Westeros so where will
you go
volantis
if you don't mind my saying I don't
think you should return to Westeros I'm
not sure you'd be safe here
I will return their Spyder one last time
your lady I have to die in this strange
country just like you this is another
reason why I think Melisandre will
ultimately sacrifice herself in the end
she already knows she is meant to die
she basically told us she will not
survive the final season we still don't
know why Melisandre is going to volantis
first but I'm assuming it's something
she feels she must do before the night
King arrives
since Melisandre left in the middle of
season 7 we may never actually see her
arrive in volantis because she is most
likely already there but I'm hoping we
could get at least a glimpse of what she
does do when she is there for those of
you that don't know when Tywin Lannister
had ice melted down and reforged into
two swords the man he hired to do this
was from volantis so perhaps this could
have something to do with the reason why
Melisandre chose to go there volantis is
one of the nine three cities in Essos
and it just happens to be one of the
greatest richest and most powerful of
the city states the fact that Melisandre
chose to go here before the great war
begins is very intriguing because there
are a number of different things she
could have planned the main motivating
factor for Melisandre going here must
have something to do with the temple of
the Lord of Light the red temple in
volantis is dedicated to her lore the
temple also happens to be protected by a
private army of slave soldiers known as
the fiery hand I think most people
believe this is exactly why Melisandre
went to volantis this relatively small
fighting force is made up of roughly
1000 soldiers who are dedicated to
serving the Lord of Light and as we all
know they are pretty much the main
religious group that is actively
opposing the great other until now no
one else really thought the White
Walkers ever existed but the followers
of roll or had been patiently waiting
for this day to come
so I imagine they will play a very big
part over the fate of the realm after
all Melisandre did tell Jon she could
help him beat the night King so she
obviously has something specific in mind
but what did she actually mean by this
I've been ready to die for many years if
the Lord was done with me so be it but
he's not you've seen the night King Jon
Snow
you know the great war still to come you
know the army of the Dead will be upon
us soon and you know I can help you win
that war I have already talked about
that scene in other videos so I don't
want to go too far down that road again
now I want to talk about some other
things Melisandre can do when she
returns to Westeros let's talk about one
of Melisandre has very special abilities
in the television show Game of Thrones
we have seen Melisandre and Thoros of
Mir bring someone back from the dead
Melisandre was able to bring back Jon
Snow and Thoris of Mir was able to bring
back beric Dondarrion in the books
beric Dondarrion also has the ability to
bring back the dead and he is able to do
this what the kiss of life which is
something he does to lady Catelyn after
she is murdered at the red wedding we
haven't seen Barrack do anything like
this in the TV show yet but I happen to
believe he could do this next season as
his grand finale
but we do know Thoris of Maher and
Melisandre can resurrect people after
Thoris of mayor brought beric Dondarrion
back to life the first time it basically
made it easier for him to do it again
because he was able to bring Barrack
back several different times so when it
comes to Melisandre now that she has
brought someone back from the dead it
may become easier for her to do this in
the future especially when you consider
she is the main representative of the
Lord of Light
I imagine Melisandre will be able to
perform her own grand finale in due time
but we don't yet know what that is
everyone will truly be tested next
season so we should see characters do
things they have never done before this
goes for characters like brain stark the
night king and even Melisandre we have
seen her create a shadow baby that was
able to kill Renly Baratheon so perhaps
she has some other crazy tricks up her
sleeve
according to Melisandre she can win big
battles with her powers but how we heard
her say this right after the Battle of
the Blackwater Bay according to
Melisandre she could have provided
enough help for them to win if Davos
would have let her go with them but what
could she have possibly done differently
I wasn't there when the Wildfire killed
our men my
thousands I could have saved those men
you would have taken the city Stannis
would now sit upon his rightful throne
and you would stand beside him but I
wasn't there because you convinced your
king to leave me behind
she also said something very similar to
Jon Snow and the clip I showed you
earlier these are at least two different
times we have heard Melisandre say that
she can win battles one thing I have
been wondering is how strong or
Melisandre is powers when it comes to
bringing people back from the dead
we know she struggled the first time
when she tried this but what next season
be in the last season I imagine every
character will be at the height of their
powers
we know HBO wants to end the show on a
very high note so I would say almost
anything is possible when it comes to
characters with magical abilities like I
said what I've been wondering is how
strong will Melisandre's powers be next
season especially when it comes to
bringing people back from the dead let's
take the night Kings Army for instance
the whites to be exact the whites are
the seemingly mindless type zombies that
make up the majority of the night king's
army we have also seen the night king
raised the skeletons of dead bodies but
what I'm referring to are the whites
that are still fully intact the bodies
that have still been somewhat preserved
in the harsh climate beyond the wall
similar to all the whites that we saw at
Hart home after the massacre at Hart
home the night King was able to raise
all those fresh dead corpses most of
which had very similar wounds that Jon
Snow and beric Dondarrion did when they
were killed and resurrected most of the
wildlings were killed by getting stabbed
and you would think their bodies would
still be preserved especially when
traveling with the night King because
the temperatures around him are much
colder than normal for many years now
fans have been wondering will brain
stark ever be able to overtake the night
Kings army since brain and the night
King had very similar powers but what
about Melisandre I don't think she would
ever be able to enter a person's mind
like brain in the night king can but
what if she was able to bring them back
to life we have seen her bring one
person back to life but what if she
learns how to do this on a much larger
scale you also have to keep something in
mind
Melisandre most likely will not return
by herself when mellow songs are first
Matt what daenerys targaryen she said
something to her that made me think she
knew more followers of her lore would be
in Westeros soon listen to what she says
to Daenerys the Lord of Light doesn't
have many photos in Westeros does he not
yes but even those who don't worship the
Lord can serve his cause as you can see
Daenerys says the Lord of Light doesn't
have many followers in Westeros
does he but Melisandre says not yet to
me that sounds like Melisandre knows
more will be coming and that most likely
has something to do with the reason
Melisandre went to volantis in the first
place I bet she plans on returning with
as many followers as possible and we
know they will all be devoted to
Melisandre cause she could come back
with kin vara the fiery hand or dozens
hundreds or thousands of people that
have been training to become a red
priest or priestess imagine if she came
back with the army that had the same
type of powers that she does then they
could definitely do things on a much
larger scale let me give you an example
now that the knight king is south of the
wall we know there is only a short
amount of time that will pass before the
great war begins as the night king moves
south he will begin decimating town
after town eventually the night king
will make it to Winterfell where almost
all the main characters are at during
the biggest battle in Game of Thrones
history the night king in his army will
kill a main character or at least a
character that we know by name it is
inevitable you can't have a battle of
that size without us suffering some
losses this is when Melisandre and
whoever she brings with her can really
assist Jon and Daenerys if the night
King would happen to try and raise the
character as a white that's when
Melisandre can step in and try to
override the night King's control or
possibly even brain star can try that
imagine if they were able to do this at
the same time the night king was trying
to turn that person into a white they
could potentially gain some insight into
how the night Kings powers actually work
and that would obviously be very
beneficial when trying to defeat him I
know it might sound crazy well let's try
to think outside of the box
another reason Melisandre could be going
to volantis is to find out more
information about the prince or princess
who was promised
not only did we see the ceremony on the
beach of Dragonstone back in the second
season but the show continues to
reference that prophecy as we get closer
to the end we all know Melisandre
originally thought Stannis was the
chosen one but she later turns her
sights on to Jon Snow however can Vora
happens to believe Daenerys is the
chosen one not to mention we did hear
missandei say the phrase is
gender-neutral which means it could be
the princess who was promised the Lord
of Light doesn't have many followers in
Westeros does he not yes but even those
who don't worship the Lord can serve his
cause
what does your Lord expect from me
Boyce's bunty's amazes me Rika vo Doral
Eris was mahogany on toss the prince who
is promised will bring the dawn I'm
afraid I'm not a prince the truth is we
need your help we'd hoped that we could
somehow persuade you to you don't need
to persuade me I came to him Daenerys
Stormborn is the one who was promised
from the fire she was reborn to remake
the Melisandre may be heading to
volantis to seek more knowledge as we
all know she does still have trouble
when looking into the flames the flames
do hold the answers but Melisandre
hasn't always been able to interpret
them correctly there should be some
other high-ranking members at the temple
who could assist Melisandre his ability
to read the flames she could also be
given more powders and potions that
could enhance all her powers maybe she
has to do something very specific in
order for the prince or princess that
was promised to come to life that could
lead to Melisandre giving a blood
sacrifice to the fire which could be
herself and only then can the chosen one
defeat the night king one thing I would
be really interested in seeing next
season as if brain and Melisandre were
actually able to work together somehow
those two characters combined would also
make up ice and fire and if they did
work together I think they could do some
real damage to the night Kings numbers
both of them have the ability to see
things but they both have problems when
trying to process that information but
if they did work as a team they might be
able to figure out a few things that
could really benefit Jon and Daenerys
his fight against the night king
at least in the television show they
both seem to be trying to do the same
thing Melisandre and brain stark want to
stop the great other from laying the
darkness over Westeros
Melisandre wants to bring the light and
Bryan did name his direwolf summer so if
they were to combine their powers they
might be able to achieve the same goal
anyways I just thought I would discuss
some other options for Melisandre today
but if you have any different ideas of
your own feel free to leave them down in
the comments section of the video now
it's time to see who won the most recent
giveaway the winner of the game of
Thrones t-shirt is Carolina Gor eBay
congratulations just make sure to send
me an e-mail that way you can pick out
your shirt and I can find out where to
send it I will start a new giveaway in
the very next video so make sure you
come back for that one to find out all
the details about how to enter I want to
thank everyone for watching today's
video I really appreciate that and I
also want to thank everyone on patreon
for supporting the channel thank you all
very much I hope you have a great day
I'll see you soon bye
you
you